YOU HAVE THE FIFTH LINE FOR
COLUMBUS BEHIND YOU.
USE IT!
>>
VANECEK ABLE TO STEER IT OFF
INTO THE CORNER. THE DRAW,
KURALY.
>> PUCK IS TIPPED.
UNDERSTANDING
THAT OSHIE WILL PROVIDE HIM THE
PUCK AS HE GETS.
A PART TOTOUS
HE'S GOT THE FIRST GOAL OF THE
GAME.
HE'S GOING TO GET THIS ONE OFF A
BOUNCING PUCK.
ROSLOVIC FOR NYQU.
THERE'S VANECEK AGAIN TO MAKE
THE STOP ANDHE FAR CORNER.
3-0 WASHINGTON CHECK
THE WHOLE WAY.
THEN HE PUTS UP THE FIVE-HOLE.
STEPPING UP, , UPPORT AND WHEN S
OUT THERE.RE WHAT
AN ADVANTAGE IN BATTLES WHEN YOU
KNOW THE
ELVIS EVER SO CALM MAKES THE
STOP.
SHOVEL RIGHT WING INTO THE
WASHINGTON ZONE.
TURNING IS NYQUIST PATTIC LAINET
WITH -- PATRIK LAINE OUT
VORACEK TURNED
THERE'S KUKAN.
HE TRIES TO COLLECT THE PUCK OFF
THE BACK HOW BIG OF AN
IMPORTANT --
HIS HEAD.
QUICK CLEAR.
YOU CAN SEE WERENSKI GOING TO
TRY TO GET UP THERE WAITING IN
THE NEAR CIRCLE DOWN LOW.
SHORT --
COMES UP HIGH HERE